معاناته خمسه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص
شردهم الزلزال في الشمال السوري يتقاسم
مروها من هجره الصراع الى ما خلف الحدود
الجنوب التركيه المنكوب للمقاطعاته 11 هنا
مليون و700 الف لاجئ من اصل ثلاثه ملايين
الف سوري يعيشون في تركيا غازي عنتاب مركز
الزلزال الاول تحتضن 460 الف لاجئ هاتاي
430 الفا 330 الفا كلس 200 الف لاجئ
وبالمناسبه عدد السوريين فيها اكبر من عدد
السكان المحليين ويساويه رسميا واحد من كل
شخصين في المقاطعات سوري وذلك بحسب مفوضيه
الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين الى من يلجا
هؤلاء في بلد اللجوء بعضهم انضم الى 40
الف متضرر احتوتهم ملاجئ ومراكز ايواء
وبعضهم وجد في العوده الى الديار كما
ذكرنا وان كانت مسحوقه او ربما لم يمتلكون
الخيار عائلات في انطاكيا توجهت الى ادلب
اللهم يحصلون على بعض المساعدات من
المنظمات المحليه والجنوب التركي لم يعد
ارضا امام الاقتصاد التركي يعاني اكثر
الاتراك بانفسهم يرون انهم الاولويات
والمساعدات لا تكفي الجميع مشاعر معاداه
السوريين ليست وليده الزلزال فكلما ضاق
العيش اتهما السوريون والتهمه هذه المره
نهب البيوت والمحلات والنتيجه اكثر من
اربعين الف سوري غادروا البلاد عدد مرشح
للزياده خاصه وان انقره منحت رخصه
استثنائيه تسمح بمغادره طالبي اللجوء
وعودتهم
قرارهن صعب اتخذه السوريون قبل سنوات وهم
يغادرون بلادهم اللاجئين اما اليوم فطريق
العوده القصريه لم تكن ايضا مفروشه
بالورود غالبيه العائدين استقرون في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه غياب
سلطه موحده جعل جهات عديده تتقاسم السيطره
على هذه المناطق عوده المعارك لن يكون
مفاجاه عكس تركيا الخيام في شمال سوريا
تعتبر الملجا الوحيد وبسبب ارتفاع الطلب
تحولت خيمه قماشيه الى حلم اسعارها قفزت
من 120 دولارا الى 300 دولار الحصول على
خيمه داخل مخيم ليس نهايه المعاناه
فالكوليرا وجدت في غياب البنيه التحتيه
وتلوث المياه مناخا مناسبا للانتشار
والاصابات قدرت بالمئات